okay really so first I guess I can't see
in front of the audience but welcome and
thank you for coming here to the yell
entrepreneurs firm um we're gonna
presently briefly to sort of attach
calls or how do you deal with the press
and why they deal with the press as I
said I've been a reporter about four
light years now possibly
Kentucky's been in PR also since
graduation class or selling um so why
don't I get started
really basic question is why in the
world we want to be listening to us and
why in the world you want to talk to the
press it's maybe not as obvious a
question as perhaps I think it is sure
hi everyone I'm Stephanie I'll start
with why talk to the press so why would
someone it approves working at a
start-up or why why do we need PR and I
would say that PR is primarily about
storytelling I think that you see a lot
of people say I'm a storyteller and and
what that means in the PR context is
really sharing your company's story with
reporters and so building credibility
and Trust showing how your product or
services innovative different and really
it's showing instead of telling which is
you know usually when you pay for
advertisements or something like that
paint begin you're basically just
telling people what you want them to
hear
whereas media is really back and forth
as you'll see later on so yeah I guess
the other question is if someone you
think convinced that you should talk to
press which is how and I think how many
people I see do this absolutely terribly
the answer is that there isn't really a
secret for how to get the kind of press
coverage that you want I'm sort of
pitching this legislative
mr. Vieau people in every kind of
smaller companies that you're not the PR
hurt Google or Facebook which is when
you pitch a journalist you don't
actually want to pitch it during the
list on who you are or what you're
making you want to put a journalist on
the idea that you can say something
that's really interesting and important
and relevant to the audience of that
newspaper or blog or TV show or whatever
and I think you know it's I still have
to get to those conversations which is
you treat journalists as if they're
human you're human and you both talk at
normal kind of English register that's
not corporate jargon or incredibly
technical language and you deserve an
email people with a high I'm really
interesting I'm relevant to you and I
should buy your coffee or should I be a
coffee and this will make both of our
conversations quite pleasant and I
notice that's really obvious that you
remember also journalists all one
different thing